konsi information flow has come let's
start with Ukraine just in the last 20
minutes we have dueling headlines on
Moria poll who's telling the truth the
rebels in Russia or Kiev well
potentially both because what the rebels
are saying is that they aren't deploying
new weapons to Mario Pole and what the
Kiev is saying is their ongoing attacks
now it seems as though there is a
pullback of heavy weapons from the from
the front lines that's not to say there
aren't still weapons there now this will
be on the topic of conversation when
foreign ministers from Russia France
Germany and Ukraine meet in Paris in
just a few hours Tom Hans when I one
more question on Ukraine I want Brenda
to pick it up on Greece this morning
what is the immediacy in Berlin and in
Brussels on Ukraine what is the jadoo
list today into Wednesday maybe even to
get to the weekend well atop the to-do
list is clarity on what's actually
happening and then if there's clarity
than moving forward on that on a policy
response but the most immediate to do is
maybe in Kiev where they have to pass
this amendment so they can get their
next tranche of IMF funding you look at
the amount of money that's come out of
the IMF there hasn't been the payment
since sep tember now they did just
approve 17.5 billion but that money
hasn't yet to be shifted over there the
overall total if you guys remember it
was 40 billion the 40 billion always
seemed a little leveraged up to me but
the fact is that money is not getting
there and they are facing a solvency of
liquidity however you want to put it a
crisis in Kiev when it comes to their
their currency all right